being effective in developing your deep
neural Nets requires that you not only
organize your parameters well but also
your hyper parameters so what are hyper
parameters let's take a look so the
parameters your model our W and B and
there are other things you need to tell
your learning algorithm such as the
learning rate alpha because um you need
to set alpha and that in turn will
determine how your parameters evolve or
maybe the number of iterations of
gradient descent you carry out your
learning algorithm has other you know
numbers that you need to set such as the
number of hidden layers so we call that
capital L or the number of hidden units
right such as zero and one and two and
so on and then you also have the choice
of activation function do you want to
use a value or ten age or Sigma little
something especially in the hidden
layers and so all of these things are
things that you need to tell your
learning algorithm and so these are
parameters that control the ultimate
parameters W and B and so we call all of
these things below hyper parameters
because these things like alpha the
learning rate the number of iterations
number of hidden layers and so on these
are all parameters that control W and B
so we call these things hyper parameters
because it is the hyper parameters that
you know somehow determine the final
value of the parameters W and B that you
end up with in fact deep learning has a
lot of different hyper parameters later
in the later course we'll see other
hyper parameters as well such as the
momentum term the mini batch size
various forms of regularization
parameters and so on and if none of
these terms of the bottom make sense yet
don't worry about it we'll talk about
them in a second pause because deep
learning has so many hyper parameters in
contrast to earlier errors of machine
learning I'm going to try to be very
consistent in calling the learning rate
alpha a hyper parameter rather than
calling a parameter I think in earlier
eras of machine learning when we didn't
have so many hyper parameters most of us
used to be a bit sloppier and just call
alpha a parameter and technically alpha
is a parameter but is a parameter that
determines the real programmers or try
to consistent in calling these things
like alpha the number of iterations and
so on hyper parameters so when you're
training a deep net for your own
application you find that there may be a
lot of possible settings for the hyper
parameters that you need to just try out
so apply deep learning today is a very
imperiled process where often you might
have an idea for example you might have
an idea for the best value for the
learning rate you might say well maybe
alpha equals 0.01 I want to try that
then you implemented try it out and then
see how that works and then based on
that outcome you might say you know what
I've changed online I want to increase
the learning rate to 0.05 and so if
you're not sure what's the best value
for the learning ready to use you might
try one value of the learning rate alpha
and see the cost function J go down like
this then you might try a larger value
for the learning rate alpha and see the
cost function blow up and diverge then
you might try another version and see it
go down really fast the converse to
higher value you might try another
version and see it you know see the cost
function J do that then after trial so
the values you might say okay looks like
this the value of alpha gives me a
pretty fast learning and allows me to
converge to a lower cost function J so
I'm going to use this value of alpha you
saw on the previous slide that there are
a lot of different hyper parameters and
it turns out that when you're starting
on a new application I should find it
very difficult to know
exactly what's the best value of the
hyper parameters so what often happens
is you just have to try out many
different values and go around this
cycle your try out some value maybe
retry five hidden layers with different
number of hidden unions implement that
Steven works and then iterate so the
title of this slide is that apply deep
learning is very empirical process and
empirical process is maybe a fancy way
of saying you just have to try a lot of
things and see what works another effect
I've seen is that deep learning today is
applied to so many problems ranging from
computer vision to speech recognition to
natural language processing to a lot of
structured data applications such as
maybe a online advertising or on web
search or product recommendations and so
on and what I've seen is that first I've
seen researchers from one discipline any
one of these try to go to a different
one and sometimes the intuitions about
hyper parameters carries over and
sometimes it doesn't so I often advise
people especially when starting on a new
problem to just try out a range of
values and see what works and then next
course will see a systematic way we'll
see some systematic ways for trying out
a range of values right and second even
if you're working on one application for
a long time you know maybe you're
working on online advertising as you
make progress on the problem it's quite
possible to the best value for the
learning rate of number of hidden units
and so on might change so even if you
tune your system to the best value of
hyper parameters today it's possible you
find that the best value might change a
year from now maybe because of the
computer infrastructure it you know CPUs
or the type of GPU running on or
something has changed but so maybe one
rule of thumb is you know every now and
then or maybe every few months if you're
working on a problem for an extended
period of time for many years just try a
few values for the hyper parameters and
double check if there's a better value
for the hyper parameters and as you do
so you slowly gain intuition as well
about the hyper parameters that work
best for your problems
and I know that this might seem like an
unsatisfying part of deep learning that
you just have to try out other values
for these hyper answers but maybe this
is one area where deep learning research
is still advancing and maybe over time
we'll be able to give better guidance
for the best hyper parameters to use but
it's also possible that because CPUs and
GPUs and networks and data cells are all
changing and it is possible that the
guidance won't to converge for some time
and you just need to keep trying out
different values and evaluate them on a
hold on cross-validation set or
something and pick the value that works
for your problems so that was a brief
discussion of hyper parameters in the
second course we'll also give some
suggestions to how to systematically
explore the space of hyper parameters
but by now you actually have pretty much
all the tools you need to do their
programming sir sighs before you do that
just share view one more set of ideas
which is I often ask what does deep
learning have to do the human brain